>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good morning.
Good morning.
I'm Marcus Brauchli of
The Washington Post.
We're one of the charter sponsors
of the National Book Festival,
big believers in reading
as you can imagine.
On behalf of the Library
of Congress,
I do welcome you to
the book festival.
We hope you're having a good day.
I want to inform you that
the presentations here
at the pavilion are being
filmed for the Library
of Congress website
and for their archives.
If you don't want to
be part of history,
you might not wanna ask questions.
And via C-SPAN for airing on
BookTV, please be mindful of these
as you enjoy the presentation.
Also, please stay away from the
risers where the cameras are
on the back, unless you want
a camera to topple on you.
And please turn off your cell
phones, pagers, or other devices
that might disturb the
person sitting next to you.
It's a special privilege
to be introducing a writer
for whom I have really
the greatest admiration.
David Hoffman is a
long time reporter
and editor for The Washington Post.
He's one of the hardest working,
most passionate believers
in the power of good
journalism to change the world
and he's been a mentor to some of
our finest foreign correspondents.
He's here today to talk about
his Pulitzer Prize-winning book,
The Dead Hand.
It's a chilling account of the
last days of the cold war and how
that era still ominously
shadows us all.
It's an extraordinary
piece of reporting
on previously unknown documents and
conversations both from this country
and from Russia where David
was stationed for the Post.
Before David mastered
the illuminated texts
of the Soviet Union, he had already
visited the Stations of the Cross
in the monastic world of
Washington journalism.
He covered the White
House in the Reagan
and George H.W. Bush
administrations.
He was the Post's diplomatic
correspondent
and as Jerusalem corespondent.
And he served as assistant
managing editor for foreign news.
It was during that last stint which
would be arduous enough for most us
that he managed to write this book.
Maybe he was able to do that
because the subject of this book
which David captures brilliantly
is urgent and compelling.
Please join me in welcoming
David Hoffman.
[ Applause ]
>> Marcus, thank you very much
and thanks to everybody for coming
on what I hope is gonna be a really
interesting and exciting day.
This book grew out of
work that I did in Moscow
as the Washington Post correspondent
there from 1995 until 2001.
I really apologize for this
hoarse voice but I'll try
and make myself very, very clear.
When I was the correspondent
in Moscow,
as American newspaper
reporter, I kept the doors
of our Moscow bureau open
and oftentimes people
who were visiting Russia for
the United States government,
for scholars and others
would come to our bureau
because they knew the door would
be open, we'd like to listen
to their experiences there,
serve them tea and cookies.
And one day, a man came to
see me in the autumn of 1998.
The door was open.
I'd never met him before.
It was a very, very
sad and sullen time
in Moscow, early autumn like today.
Only a few weeks before,
Russia defaulted
on its debts and devalued the ruble.
The great capitalist
experiment of those years seemed
to be crashing around everybody.
They-- lines were forming
outside the banks,
people couldn't get their
money out of the bank.
The money they had
been given, the bills,
the rubles were suddenly
worth much less.
They were very, very upset
and people didn't really
know what to do.
This man came to my
office and he said, "David,
I work for the United States
Department of Energy and my job is
to go and check all the nuclear
facilities here in Moscow
to make sure that all
the nuclear materials,
the highly enriched uranium and
the plutonium is locked up."
And I said, "Well, that's
really interesting work.
How do you do that?"
And he said, "Well, I have this
checklist and I go to each place
where there's uranium and
plutonium and I run down the list.
I make sure for example the
locks are properly on the doors
and that the video
cameras are working
so we can make sure nobody takes the
uranium, and we have portal monitors
and scales and all this
equipment was purchased
by the United States government
in the 1990s and given to Russia
to make sure that nobody
took the bomb-grade uranium
out of these institutes, that
nobody, no terrorists could take any
of these materials which was
laying all over the country,
1,200 tons of highly
enriched uranium spread
across 11 time zones."
But the man told me, he
said, "Today, this very day,
I had a terribly upsetting
and unsettling experience."
And I served him some more tea
and I said, "Tell me about it."
"Well, today I was at the
Institute of Theoretical
and Experimental Physics."
And I said, "That's a
beautiful institute,
it's spread out over 89
acres in the middle of Moscow
and it's an old nuclear
research institute started
in the Soviet days.
And what did you find there?"
I asked him.
And he said, "Well, you
know, I took my checklist,
I made sure the locks
were on the doors,
spread out over this
institute in small buildings,
the nuclear researchers
would do their work
with highly enriched uranium that
was brought to them in metal cans
about the size of a coffee can, the
uranium was inside and it was clad
in aluminum on the outside.
And there was a lot of uranium.
There was enough to make many, many
bombs spread over this 89 acres."
And as the man went through
his checklist that day,
he found the locks were working,
the video cameras were working,
the portal monitors were
working, everything,
all the equipment was working
but he was shocked to find
out something had gone wrong.
Something had catastrophically
wrong that we had never thought of,
because all over the
institute he found
out because the economic situation
in the country had started
to fall apart that all the
guards, all the people responsible
for watching the uranium
for preventing it
from being stolen were gone.
The guards had walked off their
jobs because they hadn't been paid.
The video monitors were running
and nobody was watching it.
This fellow who was very young,
sent by the energy department
to check all these things
had been given some cash
by the energy department, his per
diem to pay for his food every day
and he was walking around
wondering, "How do I do something
about this, what do I do?"
He called all the scientists at
the institute, all the secretaries,
anybody left he could
find into one room.
There were only 32 people he
could find on these 89 acres,
none of them were guards.
He reached into his pocket
and he took out all the money
that the Department of
Energy had given him,
3000 dollars in 100-dollar bills and
he put it on the center of the table
and he said, "Will you please
stay here until I can get help?"
And they did, because they cared
too that the uranium not be stolen.
And later, the United States
and Russia found the money
to bring the guards back.
But when this man told me the story
I thought, you know, this is 1998,
7 years after the collapse
of the Soviet Union
and there are still coffee cans
of highly enriched uranium
lying unguarded around Moscow.
The cold war had been over
for a long time and I began
to research how this came about.
Why and how was it so much
stuff was lying around,
and that's what gave rise to this
book and it's the story really
of how this enormous
amount of dangerous material
which was generated in
the cold war was dealt
with after the cold war ended
and it was a scary story and one
that didn't follow a script.
Oftentimes our politicians told
us everything was gonna be okay.
We've gone in there.
We've secured the reactors.
We've secured the weapons
facilities, but it wasn't the case.
Now I got lucky in
doing this research
because I found the records
inside the Kremlin of many
of the decisions that they had made.
And one of the things I
was determined to do was
to ask the Russians as well as
the Americans what was the story
like to you in terms of what
was happening on both sides?
We tend to forget the cold war today
but it was a colossal confrontation
of two sides and much of the history
that was written about the cold war
after it ended was
written only from one side,
from the American perspective.
It's not uncommon.
Our society is open,
our books are written,
many of our documents
were available,
but what about on the Soviet side,
the evil empire that
Reagan called it.
What were their decisions
really, really like?
What were they saying to each
other at the end of the cold war?
>> And one of the advantages
I had in this book was
to receive the papers from inside
their decision making process,
from inside their Kremlin to try
and recreate the history in stereo,
to listen and try to
understand what happened
from both sides as they lived.
A discovery that I made
was that it didn't look
like the normal narrative
that we have been told.
It looked different.
We have read books and heard
that we won the cold war
and they lost, right?
Simple, we all know Reagan's
strategic defense initiative,
won the cold war and bankrupted
the Soviet Union, right?
But actually, when you begin to
reconstruct the history as I did,
you realize that it
wasn't like that at all.
Actually the papers and
records and interviews show
that the Soviets were afraid of
the strategic defense initiative
and they were worried about
Reagan, but that country imploded,
imploded of its own
dysfunction, of its own failures.
And I like to just share with
you two very brief glimpses
of how this history looks
different in retrospect.
The first one is about that
Star Wars plan, missile defense,
that Reagan himself
announced in 1983.
You all read today headlines
about missile defense.
We're all still trying to make
up our minds whether you can
hit a missile with a missile
and shoot a bullet with
a bullet out of the sky.
But when Reagan announced this in
1983, the Soviets were very, very,
fearful and Reagan was
very, very confident.
And in fact, if you read the
literature now about the end
of the cold war, the books
are very triumphalist.
Reagan himself was the triumphalist.
He said, "This is what caused
the end of the cold war."
Well, my friends, I
just like to share
with you a discovery I had made.
I don't wanna take away from Reagan
and I'll come back
to him in a second.
But the real impact of
Reagan Star Wars was not
that he forced the Soviet Union
to build one and to be like us
and to go toe to toe with us.
The reality is that Mikhail
Gorbachev, the new leader
of the Soviet Union in March of 1985
was pressured and asked repeatedly
by people in his military, by all
those very, very powerful guys
who built rockets and
space vehicles and tanks
to build a Soviet Star Wars.
If Gorbachev hadn't come along, I'm
sure Brechnev, would have built one.
As I said, the cold war was a
collision between two huge blocks.
But this time, it would
be different.
Even as Reagan was
making his speeches,
including his second inaugural
speech given on this hall in January
of 1985, even as Reagan was saying
we will make nuclear weapons
obsolete with our Star Wars.
Gorbachev was wondering
what the hell to do.
What should he do?
Everybody was telling him
he had to do the same thing
and we made a very, very courageous
decision which is explained
in my book and in these documents.
Mikhail Gorbachev decided not to
compete, not to build the Star Wars,
not to continue the cold
war and he decided it early,
he decided it in 1985 and '86.
And this was the first turning
point that led really to the end
of the cold war and allowed
many of us to see the end
of that enormous extensive frightful
and draining confrontation.
So it wasn't only Reagan's plan
to force the Soviets to collapse,
they also made some
courageous decisions.
But, you know, I was a
White House correspondent
when Reagan was president.
I even covered his 1980
campaign for president.
I was a good reporter
in terms of taking
down everything the president
said in my notebooks.
For years I traveled around behind
Reagan taking notes what he said
trying to understand who is
this man, what did he mean.
And I have to tell you that as I
began to go through the records
in writing this book and reading
President Reagan's own diaries
which are now published, I
found a shocking discovery.
I found that contrary to many of
the things I believed and understood
in following Reagan
that he, like Gorbachev,
wanted to end the nuclear arms race.
I found out that Reagan in his
deepest emotions and beliefs wanted
to really abolish nuclear
weapons and that he wanted
to do it long before the
rest of us found out,
years before we found out.
And certainly I as a reporter,
I went back to my files,
I looked at all of my own stories
and you wont' find it in my stories
out of the White House in the 1980s.
I didn't know.
None of us knew.
So this wonderful combination
of Gorbachev's determination
to change the direction
and Reagan's hope and dream
of abolishing nuclear weapons
led us to the end of the cold war
which used-- so we almost
got even in 1986 at summit
at Reykjavik, a dramatic moment.
Now my last point is to
tell you that this sounds
like a very optimistic and
promising story and a good outcome
but the documents also revealed
something that was the underside
of the cold war, a dark side.
I found in these records evidence
with how the Soviet Union
had quietly and in violation
of all their treaty obligations
built the largest biological weapons
program that mankind had ever seen.
And in my book, I document how
scientists, thousands of them
in hidden institutes and
laboratories were ordered
by the Kremlin to create biological
weapons that were unstoppable.
They tried to take germs and create
hybrids that would cause illness
and sickness and for which
there'll be no antidotes.
There'll be no vaccines,
there'll be no antibiotics.
And this effort preceded for
years and cost billions of dollars
and ultimately the soviet
union built giant factories
to produce these germs.
And I remind you of-- sure
you've read that anthrax
in a tiny little powder
can be very poisonous.
It only takes a few
tiny little spores.
The Soviet Union built a factory
which upon given the orders
from Moscow could produce 300 pounds
of anthrax a year, enough to wipe
out every living thing
on this earth.
This factory was up and
running in exactly the time
that Mikhail Gorbachev
became president.
And one of the big mysteries of
the time is what did Mr. Gorbachev,
the great statesman who tried
to stop the nuclear arms race,
what did he do about the
germs in the basement?
What did he do about the biological
weapons that his country had built?
Well, in the end, he
didn't do anything.
He let it continue.
And when the Soviet Union ended,
when it collapsed, Americans,
like the friend who had come
to visit me that very first day
with their checklist went and they
discovered it and the book ends
with the story of how the Americans
uncovered this diabolical program
and factories to build germ weapons
to attack us in the cold war.
And it was a very, very frightening
time because we didn't know
if these factories
would be activated.
We didn't know if they could
really work, huge fermenters,
four storeys tall sitting
there in the desert
of Kazakhstan waiting to be started.
And this entire history
has a lesson for us today.
Because these horrible evil weapons
were created in a confrontation
between two political
blocks and two leaders
and it persisted for decades.
And we have to ask our
selves today why did it stop,
why did it end, and
why did it persist.
And one of the reasons was
because of the incredible mistrust
that the United States
and the Soviet Union could
not see each other clearly.
We didn't understand each other's
intentions, ways of life, ambitions.
And we have to ask ourselves today,
are we gonna get in another cold war
with somebody else
because of mistrust?
The lessons of what
happened between Reagan
and Gorbachev are things
we should think about today
when our leaders say that
we're gonna stop Iran
from building nuclear weapons.
We didn't see Gorbachev clearly nor
did Gorbachev see Reagan clearly.
And I ask you today, do we
know what's really happening
in North Korea?
Do we know what's happening in
Iran, what the leaders are thinking?
Well, the book will offer you
some insight into the dangers
of not knowing, of the
dark side of the cold war.
So, I'll be happy to
take your questions.
And thanks for coming today.
[ Applause ]
>> While you were in Russia, what
role did you see church played,
the Orthodox Church and then
all other religious groups?
>> The Orthodox Church in
Russia in the 1990s was weakened
by the 7 decades of Soviet rule.
The Soviet Union did not
completely eliminate the church.
It existed even though the
state was officially atheist.
But in the first decade after the
Union collapsed, it was impossible
for the church to get back on its
feet quickly, so it was a time
when many, many churches
were renovated
but the church itself didn't play
a big role on people's lives.
It would take many, many
years for that to happen.
Sure, I will go back and forth.
>> What's your view of Gorbachev's
organization today, Global Green
or is it called the Green Cross
internationally destroying chemical
and other weapons and what's your--
also your thoughts on the
Soviet nuclear waste and mess
and the recent book that's out on--
saying Chernobyl actually has
caused close to a million deaths.
>> First of all I think any
organization that's dedicated
to cleaning up the legacy of the
cold war deserves our support.
I ask you all, does anybody here
know how many nuclear warheads
remain in the world today?
Can anybody give me the number?
What do you think?
Do you think there's 5000
left from the cold war?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> No, 10,000 not nearly enough.
There are 23,000 nuclear warheads
today, 95 percent of them are held
by the United States and Russia.
We have a lot of work to
do to get to global zero
but I think even getting
down to a hundred
on each side wouldn't be a bad
bargain when we have 23,000 left.
So I think highly of groups that
are working to reduce this legacy
which we don't need anymore.
The cold war is over.
And the second question
was about Chernobyl.
The records suggest that it's very,
very hard to understand the impact
of radiation on human health.
Thirty or 40 people actually died
in the accident but a large amount
of radiation was spewed
across Europe and Scandinavia
and I just don't think anybody knows
how many deaths were really caused
by it, but Chernobyl
was a wake up call.
It should remind us that if we
have 23,000 nuclear warheads lying
around, there is always the
possibility of an accident.
And I think while they're well
secured and ours are secured,
Chernobyl wasn't supposed
to happen either.
They were running a
test on the reactor
and someone made a
mistake and it blew up.
What will be the next accident?
>> How did the CIA get
it so wrong for so long,
the strength of the Soviet economy?
>> You know the CIA's era here in
judging the Soviet Union was not
so much on misjudging the
strength of their economy,
it was misjudging the impact of
the weakness of their economy
on their military and
on their defenses.
In other words, we saw the
evidence with our own eyes
that there were breadlines.
You remember the dysfunctional,
failing nature of socialism.
We could see that in
the news reports
that Soviet consumers were hungry
to buy jeans on the street.
They had never had any
factory that made jeans, right?
But what we didn't understand
was that corrosive failure
of socialism also was cutting
into the rocket forces,
cutting into the missiles
and it was making them unable
to actually launch anything,
and frankly the Korean airliner
that was shot down in 1983,
that horrible tragedy was shot
down by a mistake because their
radar's didn't even work properly.
So the error here and the error
that Reagan made himself was
that we wanted to see that socialism
was failing and we wanted capitalism
to triumph and we understood
breadlines
but we saw the military
as 10 feet tall.
And they weren't.
They had suffered the same
malaise, the same dysfunction.
And that was hard to grasp
but it was a time of secrecy,
a time of spies, a time
of great confrontation.
I don't know that we
should fault the CIA per se.
Nobody saw it because they
hid their weakness behind
that mistrust and secrecy.
Which side am I on?
I forgot.
>> How do you view
the New START Treaty
and how do you think it
compares to START treaty?
>> Well I just finished saying
that there are 23,000
nuclear warheads left.
Here's a new treaty that will
come to 1550 on each side, right,
so it sounds like a good deal.
That's only 3000 some all together.
Except that we're gonna
put a whole lot of them
in storage and not count them.
This treaty ought to be
ratified, but don't fool yourself.
The job is not finished.
When it's over, there's still gonna
be another 10 or 15,000 in storage.
I'm sorry, but if you just
put another name on it
and say it's a nuclear
weapon in storage,
you haven't made the world safer.
We have more work to
do after the treaty.
>> You mentioned Iran
toward the end of your talk,
how do you feel the uranium
that is still floating
around has impacted what's
going on in Iran today
and how does it affect what's
going on in the Middle East?
>> Well, as a general statement,
we'll all be a lot safer
if no more countries obtain nuclear
weapons and decide to use them
and build them and test them.
Now, how they get the
uranium, the difficult process
of understanding what
their thought process.
Why did they want the bomb,
who were their enemies,
we need to think about that.
We cannot always see Iran
as some kind of a boogeyman
like we did the Soviet Union.
It requires us to be
more sophisticated
to understand what the
leadership really wants by this.
But whether North Korea or Iran
or some place else,
the fewer the better.
>> Would you comment on the role
that President Herbert Walker
Bush played during the collapse
of the Soviet Union to
the satellite nations?
>> I described-- I
described in the book
that President George Herbert Walker
Bush whom I covered, you know,
was very close and understood what
Reagan had done in the last years
of Reagan's presidency, and he
didn't wanna do the same thing.
While Reagan was a nuclear
abolitionist, Bush was not.
Bush was much more of a
conventional nuclear deterrence guy,
that had been his upbringing.
So the first thing he did really
in 1989, in that historic year
of change in 1989 is
he put the brakes on.
He slowed everything down.
And I think it was a mistake.
It was a pause in everything
that was going on in 1989
when there was great chance for
him to strike a deal with Gorbachev
to exploit everything
that Reagan had done.
But by the end of 1989,
the Berlin wall fell down.
It was pretty hard to
ignore the signs of change.
And then Bush got into gear in 1990.
And in many ways, I think Bush
himself saw himself as a president
who represented prudence, a
word that he loved, caution,
and it was a time of enormous change
and he was not a person
of enormous change.
He did what he though was
the right thing at that time.
>> A couple of things, what do you--
what happened to the
biological weapons
that they had on the Soviet Union.
And also, when you talk
about the lack of knowledge
with what's happening
in Iran and North Korea,
are you suggesting
maybe greater engagement
or possible military action?
>> On the biological
weapons of the Soviet Union,
many of them have been destroyed.
We found the factories,
thanks to the courageous work
of some Americans who I
described in the book.
We bulldozed some of those
factories, but not all of them.
There are three biological weapons
laboratories remaining inside Russia
today that have never
been opened to the west.
Nobody knows what's going on inside.
Our program was closed down
by Richard Nixon in 1969.
We obeyed the treaty.
Soviet Union and Russia
also signed the treaty.
It's time for them to come clean.
I'm against military
action against Iran.
I don't think it will help anything.
We've got two wars going on and
I don't think we need a third.
And in terms of engagement, yes, you
know I always come back to the kind
of engagement Reagan argued for,
even in the height of the cold war.
We talked to the Soviet leaders.
We had an embassy in Moscow.
We do not have one in Tehran.
Why is it that we can't
have the same engagement?
But Reagan always said,
you know, trust but verify.
Well, if we're cautious, there's
no reason we can't engage further
with Iran.
>> We have time for
one more question.
>> Okay, so you talked
about materials,
what about the scientists
and the know-how?
>> We know very little what
happened to the scientists.
An American program was
started to help the scientists.
It was estimated there were 60,000
scientists with weapons knowledge
and they're at the core
and we had to help them.
We don't know how many,
we reached some of them.
They got small stipends or grants.
We tried to help but nobody
knows what really happened
to all the know-how to this day.
Thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.